[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS HAYES: Hey, everybody.
TORRENCE BOONE: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm Torrence Boone.
I'm a VP in the global
business organization
looking after our global
business with advertising
agencies.
And I also lead our global
brand services team.
Thank you all for coming out.
I have the distinct
pleasure and privilege
of introducing Chris Hayes.
In many ways, he doesn't
need an introduction.
But he is the Emmy award
winning host of "All In
with Chris Hayes" on MSNBC.
He is a "New York
Times" bestselling
author of "Twilight
of the Elites"
and an editor-at-large
at "The Nation."
His newest book is "A
colony In a Nation."
And that's what we're
going to spend time
talking about this afternoon.
So Chris, why don't we just
start with your inspiration.
What inspired you to write
this incredibly important book?
CHRIS HAYES: I think
there were two things.
One was the time I spent
in Ferguson, where,
after Michael Brown's
death in 2014,
I was reporting from there.
And I'm a city kid.
I grew up here in New York
City in the Bronx in the 1980s.
And the idea of tensions
with police and all of that
was not foreign to me.
But I think there's a weird kind
of provincialism when you're
from New York, where you think
everything is just a New York
thing.
TORRENCE BOONE: The bubble.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
So what was mind-blowing to
me about Ferguson was here
was this heretofore anonymous
hamlet, 20,000 people,
municipality that
is largely known
for being in between places,
or people are coming and going
in the St. Louis metro area,
in which there was essentially
a kind of predatory police state
that was systematically preying
on its citizens, a majority
black municipality in which 53
of the 55 officers in the
police department were white,
in which all but one
council member was white,
in which the mayor was white,
the city manager was white.
And every single person
there that I talked to,
every person of color
that I put a microphone to
or my tape recorder
or my notepad,
could tell a story about
harassment and predation,
everything from a
state senator who
told the story about
being at a fair when
she was 16 with a fire
truck that you could go in.
And the firefighter invited
her to go in, and going in,
and next thing
she knows, there's
a cop with a gun
drawn on her, saying,
get the fuck out of there.
Can I say that?
Is that--
TORRENCE BOONE: This
is being edited.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah, yeah.
I like to take advantage
when I'm not on air,
scream the profane inclinations.
And I had this thought
as I was in Ferguson
of just the degree to
which law enforcement there
felt like an occupying
force from another entity,
that the basic--
and I mean this in a kind of
almost phenomenological sense.
I mean it in a kind
of subjective sense,
that the sensation of
democratic accountability
was completely absent.
It was obviously
ostensibly democratic.
There's voting, and there's
elected representatives.
But it felt, to me observing
it, and to the people
that I was talking to,
like an occupying force,
occupied territory.
And I was thinking
about that when
I started to think about
writing a book because I was
in Baltimore in the wake
of Freddie Gray's death
and came upon Richard Nixon's
1968 convention speech
in Miami, which is an
interesting speech.
It's sort of his famous
law and order speech.
It's given, of course, in one of
the most violent and tumultuous
years in American history,
basically after the Civil War,
I would say.
Martin Luther
King's assassinated.
RFK is assassinated.
Riots, protests, et cetera.
And he gives this
big law and order
speech where he basically makes
an argument to restore order.
He says, tonight is
time for some frank talk
about the problem of order
in the United States.
And there's a throwaway
line in there where he says,
black Americans want the
same as white Americans.
They don't want to
just have handouts.
They don't want to be
a colony in a nation.
And there was something
about that phrase
that seemed both sort of
profound and elemental
to me precisely because
our inheritance is
as a former colony that became a
nation and the degree to which,
when I sort of connected
back to that experience
that I'd seen firsthand in
Ferguson and in Baltimore,
of a kind of
colonial experience,
that it sort of
locked into my head
that we'd sort of created these
two different regimes, which
is not at all in any
way a novel insight.
And in fact, there's a
lot of, frankly, books
better than mine on the topic
that I would urge you to read
and are cited.
But then the question
for me became why?
What is the origin?
Why did we democratically
produce this?
And that's in some ways the
kind of project of the book.
TORRENCE BOONE: So one of the
really interesting dimensions
of the book is your linkage
of the early American
colonialists' set of
motivations to the condition
of black and brown
people in urban America.
Take us back because there's
some interesting parallels.
There's the little-known
fact of John Hancock
as a bit of a criminal.
CHRIS HAYES: He was a smuggler.
TORRENCE BOONE: Right.
So talk so that linkage.
CHRIS HAYES: So we all learned
that the American Revolution
was about taxation, right?
No taxation without
representation.
And at some level, it was.
But taxation is a
really misleading term
because we all think of
taxes in the modern sense
of the bureaucratic
state, in which we
have payroll taxes deducted.
And we file our taxes
in April 15, et cetera.
All taxes at that
time are essentially
controlled through tariffs.
And Britain, of course, at this
time is a mercantilist empire.
And the basic kind of
framework for mercantilism,
precisely the subject of
the critique of Adam Smith's
"Wealth of Nations,"
published in 1776,
is that essentially, you
conquer other territories.
And you regulate the
exchange of trade.
And you take a
cut of everything.
And that's how you
fund the government.
And so what this meant
was the colonies,
it was actually
illegal, essentially,
to import things from
non-British colonies
or non-British territory.
And what this meant
was that it was
an unbelievable black market.
Molasses was largely coming
from French and Dutch colonies.
And molasses was
necessary to make rum.
And the colonies were probably
the world's biggest rum
producer per capita.
That's, like, the one thing
the colonies made, was rum.
And that rum was actually
central to the slave
trade and the triangle trade.
The rum was actually, because
it could be stored in barrels
and could be traded in
the Gold Coast of Africa,
was actually used
to pay for slaves.
That rum was essential to
the entire economic lifeblood
of the colonies.
And it was essentially
being built off
the back of an illegal import.
And so what that
meant was smuggling
was absolutely essential to
the economy of the colonies
at the time, not that
different from the way
that black market economies,
gray market economies, drug
economies become
essential to neighborhoods
that are outside the bounds of
legitimate and legal markets.
John Hancock was a big smuggler.
The smugglers basically
ran the town of Newport.
They ran much of Boston.
And the thing that happens
is that after the French
and Indian War, the British find
themselves with a huge deficit.
And they decide they're going to
recoup the deficit by beginning
to enforce all the smuggling
laws that they've essentially
been ignoring.
So for all those years,
there's this sort
of wink and nod approach.
There's barely enough
customs officers.
The customs officers basically
never bring any cases.
The smugglers go
about their business.
Everyone knows what's happening,
but looks the other way.
And then a crackdown.
And the crackdown is
a policing crackdown.
It is a law
enforcement crackdown
because the means by
which taxes are collected
are through customs agents.
It's not accountants.
It's not bureaucrats.
It's actual boats being
pulled over and searched.
Customs enforcement ramps up.
And they begin what I call
in the book the first stop
and frisk era.
Ships are being pulled over in
ports, customs agents crawling
all over these businesses.
And it makes the
colonists furious.
Benjamin Franklin
writes about how insane
it is to use the Navy to start
searching your own citizens
and militarizing the police.
There's a famous case
in a courtroom in Boston
in which lawyers
defend smugglers who
have been illegally searched.
And John Adams later
in his life would say,
everyone who watched
that argument in court,
there and then was a spark
of independence born.
In the Declaration
of Independence,
Thomas Jefferson
writes in his bill
of particulars about the
king that one of his offenses
is that he has sent
hither swarms of officers
to harass our people and
eat out their substance.
He has sent hither swarms of
officers to harass our people
and eat our substance.
That is Jefferson saying, fuck
the police, quite literally.
And officers means officers,
means law enforcement.
And so you have this sort
of remarkable situation
in which the actual point of
contact, the real sort of spark
to the flame of the revolution
is a law enforcement problem.
It is stop and frisk.
It is harassment.
It is the feeling of
humiliation that the colonists
feel at the hands
of law enforcement.
That is the thing that
really gets people amped up.
And it's something that--
it's our inheritance as a
nation at some level, right?
The idea that we would
just sit and take it
while an officer
searches us unlawfully
was, in almost a
literal sense, what
we fought the Revolution over.
TORRENCE BOONE: We're gonna
come back to revolution.
But connect that to Ferguson
and traffic citations
and the kind of exploitation
that is parallel,
but in a contemporary context.
CHRIS HAYES: So one
of the things that's
so insane about Ferguson and the
way Ferguson operated-- and I
think it's actually
quite distinct
from, say, New York, which has
its own policing problems--
is that in an almost direct
parallel to the customs
agents and colonial enforcement,
Ferguson law enforcement
functioned primarily as a
revenue-generating operation.
And this is not
my determination.
It's the determination of
the United States Department
of Justice, which issued an
unbelievable scathing and
eye-opening patterns
and practices
report about the police
department in Ferguson,
in which they said that,
essentially, revenue
generation was the
primary objective rather
than public safety.
And there are all
these insane emails.
Like, the city manager
being like, well,
have you staffed up
the revenue pipeline
on this stretch of road?
And they're like, no.
We're going to get some
more people over there
so we can prime the pump and
get some more money flowing in.
So rather than raise
property taxes,
rather than raise taxes, which
is politically difficult,
the police department in
Ferguson essentially operated
as a means of extracting revenue
and preying upon the mostly
black residents of the
city and constructed
all sorts of increasingly
insane, enraging, and Byzantine
means of doing this, including
municipal court summons.
You get a ticket for $100.
And then you get a
summons to go to court.
But they did this
really crafty thing
where court would be
open for three hours
on a Monday and a Wednesday.
And that's it during the week.
And then all the people
with a summons have to go.
Keep in mind, they're
issuing every year
about two traffic citations
per resident of the town.
OK?
Now, in fairness, there's a
lot of people going through.
But you get the idea.
So then you go
with your summons.
You'd have to take
a half day off work.
And oh, you know what?
The line's too long.
You didn't get in.
You're now in contempt.
They really did this.
And now you're in contempt.
Now you've got a warrant.
So the next time you
get a traffic ticket,
you get pulled over.
Oh, there's a warrant.
Now you're in cuffs
because you're in contempt.
There is a story of
a woman who ended up
doing three nights in
jail and paying about $600
for an initial $50 traffic
ticket and still owed $500.
Because the other
thing they would
do is sort of attach these
kind of payday lending interest
rates on the fines.
So you couldn't
come up with $150,
or you couldn't get to
court in time to pay it,
then there would be this massive
penalty fees and late fees.
And so they constructed this
incredibly crude, avaricious,
Rube Goldberg machine
of revenue extraction
that was entirely
dependent upon the citizens
that, ostensibly, they
were there to protect,
but who were, essentially,
moving targets
for this project of
revenue extraction.
And again, to go back
to the colonists,
this was what the
colonists fought.
To use law enforcement as a
tool of revenue extraction
is a perversion
of, I think, what
our sort of communal
intuitions are about what
we want police to do, right?
It's keep us safe.
And so it was really
striking to me
just how perverse Ferguson
was and how directly
it connected to the kind
of initial conditions
of the colony.
TORRENCE BOONE: And
obviously, that experience
of the residents in Ferguson,
the exploitation that you just
described, was a
key underpinning
to the response
to Michael Brown.
So take us back to that time
where you were covering.
What was it like?
You spend a lot of time in the
book talking about white fear.
And you bring a number of images
of the streets of Ferguson
during that time.
So dimensionalize that for us.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
I think you could see there
was a tremendous amount of rage
and humiliation in Ferguson.
But on the other side
of it was this kind
of terrified
white-knuckle white fear
that things were going
to get out of control.
And I'll never forget this
one press conferences.
This was after the--
Michael Brown was shot
and killed on, I believe,
a Saturday night.
The sort of quick [INAUDIBLE] is
burned in unrest the next night
on Sunday.
And then there's
huge police presence,
famously huge, militarized
police presence
for a small number of protesters
on Monday and Tuesday night.
And the Tuesday night, I think,
was when the reporters were
arrested in the McDonald's.
There's crazy footage
of tear gas being
fired into people's front
yard, tear gas being
fired at an Al Jazeera camera.
And finally, Jay
Nixon, the governor,
has a press conference
the next day.
And it's crazy.
We're at this press
conference, and there's
two kinds of reporters.
There's local reporters,
and then there's
national, international
reporters.
And the national,
international reporters
are all being like, why do
you have SWAT teams aiming
long guns at four
dozen protesters
in the middle of the street?
And the local
press is all, like,
are you just going
to let everyone riot?
Just gonna hand over
the streets to 'em?
And I remember being like, we
are seeing this differently.
And I don't want to disparage
the local press there,
who by and large did a
great job covering it.
And we were in from out of town.
And I don't want to sort of
pull rank on them in any way
because it was their story,
and they did a great job
reporting it.
So just to make that clear.
But what I think was happening
was there were concerns
of a lot of the local
audience there--
and I think particularly
white metro St. Louis--
that was primarily concerned
with things getting out
of hand.
And I recognized that concern
for things getting out
of hand because I have a
concern with things getting out
of hand.
And I grew up in New York
City in the '80s and '90s,
and this deep, kind
of neurotic fear
of disorder, of broken windows,
of chaos, of unruliness,
I have that.
I was sort of raised with it.
I think there's parts of
it that are universal.
I don't think anyone loves
huge amounts of unrest.
But there's also
parts of it that I
think are very specific
to a particularized kind
of white fear, a fear
that the social order will
be overturned.
And I think that,
in particular, is
one of the sort of strands
of the nation's cultural DNA
that goes all the way
back to the first moment
the first ship
lands at Jamestown,
when the captain writes
in his first diary entry,
we were set upon by the savages.
The first moment.
And it extends through the
settling and the frontier
and the fear that stalks the
nightmares of the slavers,
that they will be caught in a
rebellion, which, by the way,
was incredibly prescient fear.
I didn't quite
realize the degree
to which a huge amount of
Southern newspapers that
were read by the
planter class are just
accounts of rebellions.
This constant kind of,
like, if you're not careful,
they're coming for you.
And we as a society--
I particularly think white
Americans are real inheritors
of that tradition.
And I could feel
the ambient anxiety,
and particularly when I would go
to the other parts of Ferguson
and talk to the
folks that were sort
of on the other side of the
protests, which were people who
were putting out
I-heart-Ferguson lawn signs,
where there was this impromptu
kind of counterprotest that
had been organized by a
former mayor in a coffee shop.
And people were giving
out the yard signs.
And it's a very different
demographic there.
It was almost entirely
white, where people were,
this is a good place,
and we need order.
And it's terrible what
happened to that young man,
but we need order.
TORRENCE BOONE: So
if we take white fear
as a point of
departure, link that
to our gun policies, the
criminal justice system.
You spend a lot of time
talking about how those two
forces really drive a lot of the
dysfunction that we experience.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
So I think that the fear sort
of moves in different directions
and takes different
objects and is the source
of the incredibly
punitive criminal justice
system that we've erected, the
largest carceral state that's
ever been built--
5% of the world's population,
25% of its prison population.
One out of every four prisoners
in the world is an American,
which maybe you know
that and maybe you don't.
But I always try to
picture that in my head.
There's got to be a lot of
prisons in India and China,
right?
Don't you guys have
that interview question
about how many piano
tuners in New York?
Isn't that a thing?
Am I right about that?
Am I recalling that correctly?
Or was that a myth?
Yeah, that was a myth.
TORRENCE BOONE: That's
for the engineers.
CHRIS HAYES: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
All Right.
Just trying to think
about, picture that--
there's a lot of
prisons in the world.
It's a big world.
And one out of every
four is an American.
So in the construction of that,
and particularly in the 1960s,
its sort of law
and order moment,
which I write about in the
book, is a particularized way
in a particular historical
context amidst these twin
phenomena of-- well,
three phenomenon--
backlash to the civil
rights movement,
actual rising crime in a--
incredibly steeply rising crime.
Country's getting much, much
more dangerous much more
quickly.
And also, sort of
social disorder--
protests, things like that,
that we sort of attach ourselves
to this politics
of law and order.
In terms of the
role that guns play,
the gun has always
been central here.
I mean, to go back to
the Jamestown experience,
it's like, how did
they win that one?
And the gun is the answer.
How was the West won?
The West was won with guns.
How was the sheer
numerical force
of slaves on the
plantation kept subdued?
Through torture, psychological
torture, repeated violence,
and the gun.
So the gun is
central at one level
because the gun is the central
implement that is constantly
attached to the
project of conquering
and of civilizing,
of maintaining order.
And at the same time,
the gun is also this sort
of looming specter for police.
So think about the
difference between policing
a country like Japan and
policing Los Angeles.
So you show up to a domestic
disturbance in Japan.
People argue in Japan, right?
They're people.
Just
TORRENCE BOONE: Just softly.
CHRIS HAYES: And people
get mad at each other.
And someone's mad
at someone else.
And you show up.
And you got to try
to sort it out.
And maybe someone's
violating some municipal code
or legal provision.
Or maybe there's
actually been an incident
of domestic violence.
But it's just not going to
happen that someone's gonna
pull out a gun and shoot you.
Statistically, that's
just not gonna happen.
In the US, it could.
There's one gun for every man,
woman, and child in the United
States of America.
And the way that
police train is they
train for that, in some ways
in the way that all workplace
safety training is about
training for the extraordinary.
If you're working
on an assembly line,
you can go 20 years without
a huge, terrible accident.
But when you train, you
train for the accident.
What police train for is
they train for someone
taking out a gun and shooting
them when they pull someone
over for a traffic stop.
TORRENCE BOONE: And
by the way, there's
an amazing part of the
book where Chris actually
goes through a VR experience
as a police trainee.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
They have, sort of, this
300-degree thing, where
it's this interactive scenario.
TORRENCE BOONE: He
didn't do very well.
CHRIS HAYES: I was terrible.
Which is sort of the point.
It's a little bit
of cop propaganda
because they like bringing
know-it-all pundits
to walk a mile in our shoes.
And I was like, well, you
just shot nine people.
It was like, oops.
Not so easy.
Like, I pulled my gun
on a guy who was gonna
throw a cinder block at me.
Like, the first thing.
And the trainer was like,
should you have pulled your gun?
I was like, probably not.
Fair point.
But they have these
virtual-reality training
sessions.
And they're actually the
ones that cops train on.
And again, I want to be fair and
honest and sort of empathetic
here about the
fact that policing
a country with the
level of gun violence
we have and the ubiquity of guns
really does fundamentally alter
the experience of policing.
And so there's a degree to
which every time we hear,
went for the gun.
He went for my gun.
He went for a gun.
I thought he was
going for a gun.
Amadou Diallo was
taking out his wallet
when he was shot and
killed in New York City.
And there's something
maddening, maddening
about that, horrifying,
unjust, but also,
in the psychology of these
cops, I think not crazy.
TORRENCE BOONE: And we have
a global audience here.
One of the distinctions
that you make as well
is the difference between
the American criminal justice
system and the European
criminal justice system
and how the lack of an
aristocracy in this country
in many ways contributed
to the harsher dynamics
of our criminal justice system.
Talk a little bit about that.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
There's a great book on this
by a Yale professor named
James Whitman called "Harsh
Justice," which is comparative
between the US and Europe.
And the main thrust
of his argument
is that Europe basically
had twin justice
systems for commoners
and for aristocrats.
And the aristocratic
system was quite forgiving.
And the commoner one was harsh.
And the progress of
continental legal traditions
was to level up the
commoner treatment
to the aristocratic one.
And you've probably seen
articles or photo essays
about Danish jails, where
they have two-bedroom suites
and hot tubs.
And it's like a whole genre
of about like how, wow.
And in the US, there was
no division, obviously,
which is not to say
there weren't divisions,
like slaves had a completely
unique set of punishments.
But America has this deep
sort of punitive leveling-down
instinct.
Obviously, it's the
nation of the stocks,
of the scarlet letter
This is deeply embedded.
But we still have this impulse.
You still see this
impulse, I think, even
among progressives, people of
the left, social-justice types,
to level down, that the sort
of way we could get to equality
is to punish more
harshly at the top.
And I think sometimes that's
a totally fair impulse.
It's demanded by justice.
There's a tremendous amount of
lack of elite accountability.
I mean, we see it on
display right now in ways
that I find completely
stroke-inducing.
But I also think that
the real tough nut
to crack as a society in
terms of our kind of shared
socio and political
emotional lives
is finding spaces for
empathy and forgiveness.
And I was just this morning--
this is my second
event of the day.
This morning, I
hosted a fundraiser
for an amazing organization
called the Osborne Association
that works with the currently
incarcerated and the formerly
incarcerated and their
families and their loved ones.
And it's an incredible
organization.
I'd urge you all to look
into it and consider
contributing to it.
But what's so
profound about this
is that everyone
living around this
is dealing with how to
think about forgiveness
and redemption, including people
who have taken someone's life
and are thinking about how to
do that first for themselves,
to make restitution, to try to
make themselves a whole person,
but also to reconcile with
the sort of inescapable horror
of what they've done and
the harm they've committed.
And in some strange way,
it's like the conversation
we have about victims
and crime is so removed
from the amazing emotional
work that those folks, who
are in the midst of
it, who are dealing
with the perpetrators of genuine
terrible harm, are doing.
And I think one of
the things that we
take comfort in when we think
about the criminal justice
system or we say reform is
nonviolent drug offenders.
Right?
If you let every nonviolent
drug offender out
of American prisons
today, we would still
be the most incarcerated
country in the world.
OK?
So getting down to Dutch
or Danish or French levels
of incarceration means
letting out violent offenders,
and that means people
who did terrible things--
committed rape,
committed assault,
committed armed
robbery, shot people.
And that means do we need to
keep a 62-year-old in prison
another eight years
who shot someone?
Not innocent.
They shot someone.
They did something horrible.
20% of New York prisoners--
20% of prisoners in New York--
are over the age of 60.
There are 85-year-olds
on Rikers.
Why are we doing that?
TORRENCE BOONE:
We're going to move
to open Q&A. So if
you guys want to head
to mics if you have questions.
So just staying on that,
because I'm glad you said that.
And it's interesting that you
say that because my question
was around the endgame.
Because in the book, you
quote Frantz Fanon and say,
"colonialism is not
a thinking machine,
nor a body endowed with
reasoning faculties.
It is violence in
its natural state,
and it will only
yield when confronted
with greater violence."
So my question was, are
we headed to revolution?
It sounds like you feel that
there is the opportunity
for reconciliation.
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
I mean, I'm not--
Fanon was speaking about a
specific context and generally
a revolutionary and
places like Algeria.
I think that the differences
between our situation
and theirs are sort of more
salient in that respect
than the similarities in
terms of the way forward.
But the streets of
Baltimore felt revolutionary
after Freddie Gray.
And Ferguson felt revolutionary.
There's a certain amount of--
I mean, humiliation is a
particularly potent force
driving human affairs because
the humiliated subject cannot
act on their humiliation as
a definitional truth about
humiliation.
Being humiliated in the
moment means taking it.
Right?
The cop calling you a name
when they pull you over.
Got to take that.
So humiliation has an
ability to be bottled up,
and then explode.
The Arab Spring started over a
cop harassing a street vendor.
This cop had harassed
this street vendor,
Mohamed Bouazizi,
time and time again,
who was selling fruit
without a permit.
Eric Garner was selling
cigarettes that were untaxed.
And eventually,
that fruit vendor,
after being slapped by the
cop one day and yelled at,
lit himself on fire in Tunisia.
And that was the start
of the Arab Spring.
So there is a kind of
powder keg to the experience
of humiliation
that I worry about.
I also, though, do think
that one of the things that's
been interesting is as
polarizing as Black Lives
Matter and protests have
been, public opinion
has moved in their direction
really significantly, actually.
It's interesting.
It shows up in Pew, and
it shows up in Gallup.
And this is true
among white Americans.
Questions about how often
police mistreat people,
their concern about
whether there's
equal justice in the criminal
justice system, these
have all moved in BLM's
direction in last year.
So I think, actually, as brutal
as the backlash has been,
and as much friction
as there is around it,
it is actually moving public
opinion in the right direction.
It can be hard to
see that at times.
But it is moving in
the right direction.
TORRENCE BOONE: Good.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I have a
semi-serious question
and a serious question.
My semi-serious-- first of
all, I'm a Bronx guy like you.
So shut out to the Bronx.
But also, I just wanted to
ask about the book cover.
Because for me as
a New York guy,
that cover looks exactly like
the typeface of "The New York
Daily News," which in my era
was the conservative newspaper.
CHRIS HAYES: Right.
It was the tabloid of the right.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
I was just wondering if
that was an accident.
Because just looking at it,
my head started to shake.
CHRIS HAYES: No, actually,
I think graphically,
it's actually more inspired
by the "I am a man" signs
from the March on
Washington, which
if you go back
and look at those,
it actually sort of looks like.
I did not design the cover.
But I wanted something stark.
And I think, actually,
tabloid headlines
was in my head a little bit.
I wanted something
that was all text.
AUDIENCE: And the
more serious question,
which I don't think
there's an easy answer to--
so you did touch on
this a little bit
about the dichotomy
between excessive policing,
but the sort of inchoate feeling
of the general population
that they want more security.
And so, like you,
growing up in New York--
I'm older than you.
But I remember the '60s
and the '70s in the Bronx.
And even right down the
street here at Chelsea,
I went to college down here.
And this was--
I say this to younger
Googlers than me,
and they look at me like I'm
talking about the American
Civil War.
But in the 1970s, if you
were in this neighborhood
and you were out past
8 o'clock at night,
there was probably
a really good chance
that you were gonna get
mugged or worse down here.
And so after all this research
and thinking about this,
do you see a place where
that balance exists
between the genuine need
for security and sort
of overstepping bounds?
CHRIS HAYES: It's a
really great question.
So yeah, I want to
be clear on this,
that what happens
with crime and danger
in the United States
between 1966 and 1993
isn't some fiction.
When I started commuting down to
Manhattan from the Bronx, where
I grew up, to go to a magnet
school in the Upper East Side
in 1992, there was 2,300
murders in New York City.
Last year, there were 350.
I mean, think about if child
poverty dropped by that amount,
right?
Or expanded by that amount.
Any sort of social metric that
went up as much as crime did,
and then went down
as much, would
have huge political and
social consequences.
Now, the issue
partly-- and there's
a chapter in the book
about broken windows.
At the core of the
issue is the fact
that crime drops
between '92 and 2014.
And it's one of the great
sociological mysteries
of our time.
We just don't know.
It probably comes
down to a layering
of a variety of factors.
There's a demographic
component to it.
In the beginning, the
increase in incarceration
probably does part of it, too.
If you think of a
thought experiment,
if you took a society, and then
you put every male 18 to 24
in prison, the
crime would go down.
It would.
That would obviously be
unjustifiable across any sort
of moral, political framework.
But as a raw--
and there's neighborhoods
where that basically was done.
So incarceration probably
played some role.
There is the
argument about lead,
that lead played a huge role
in the increase in crime,
and then the unleaded gasoline
and catalytic converters
went down.
And then there's the
question about policing.
So the reason I'm
laying the groundwork
is because the story, which is
not a crazy story that I think
generations of
politicians, police
officials, and the
public have learned,
is that the bad old days happen,
and then Bill Bratton came in,
and they started broken-windows
policing and Rudy Giuliani,
and that was spread
across the country.
And that caused
the crime decline.
And so now you've got this
kind of, it's almost this--
I describe it in the book
as cargo cult thinking.
It's like rain dance.
There's the cause
and the effect.
So it's like you have to devote
yourself to the crime gods.
Because if you don't,
then the bad old days
are going to come back.
And in some ways,
I understand why
particularly police
professionals who oversaw
that period think they did it.
i would think I did it, too.
And there's no
question, I think,
that some policing is
better than others.
But I also think we
have to recognize
that a lot of
nonpolicing factors
were driving that,
which brings us
to the great
stop-and-frisk experiment.
Because the warning,
when the city settled
the stop-and-frisk lawsuit, from
people like Ray Kelly and all
sorts of folks was the bad
old days are gonna come back.
And they haven't.
So New York City--
and that's an environment in
which a lot of top 25 cities
have seen really worrying
rises in homicide,
seriously upsetting rises--
Chicago, Baltimore, Cleveland,
St. Louis, Milwaukee.
New York's gone down.
But it gets to this really
deep, fundamental point
because you're seeing the
politics of law and order
in those cities go right back
to the politics of law and order
in the 1970s.
TORRENCE BOONE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit
about the Philadelphia DA
primary that just happened
and what do you think
the significance of that
going forward and whether
that's a model for--
CHRIS HAYES: I'm glad
you brought that up.
I mortifyingly
misspoke this morning
and said it was the election,
not the primary, when
I was speaking at Osborne.
And then someone told me.
And I wanted to crawl
into a corner and die.
So 90% of my cognitive
energy for the last six hours
has gone to that.
Why did I make that mistake?
It's a primary.
Now I can get that back.
So I tell people all the time
on book talks, what can I do?
And the thing I say is, we
focus on the federal government.
But the criminal
justice system--
and this is a point
that's really made well--
It's made well in James
Forman's great book,
"Locking Up Our Own,"
which I recommend,
and "Locked In" by John
Pfaff, which is out-- which
is that there is no single
criminal justice system.
It's literally thousands of
systems, like county sheriffs,
municipal DA's, all these
different interlocking systems
at the local level, and
a lot of elected leaders
who are elected in super
low-turnout elections, which
in some ways is the
good news because it
means you have a lever.
If you devote
yourself to working
on these issues in
local elections,
you can have a huge impact.
And the Philadelphia
primary is probably
the most stunning
example of that so far.
A guy named Larry Krasner, who
is a sort of notorious lefty
lawyer of Philadelphia--
he's the lawyer that is there
when a bunch of protesters
are arrested at a protest
to bail them out.
He has no prosecutorial
experience.
And the police union hates
him and, in the manner
of police unions everywhere,
was not shy about saying that.
Police unions tend to
speak in one register.
I don't know if you've noticed
this from official police union
statements.
And Krasner won this
primary explicitly
on a program of reform.
He's not the first sort
of reformer DA to win.
There's a woman in Orlando
who won similarly and is now
locked in a battle with
the state Republicans who
want to take her power away
because she said she's not
going to use the death penalty.
There's a woman in
Cook County, Illinois,
who grew up in
[INAUDIBLE] who also
won and unseated the
district attorney--
or I guess in Illinois,
it's the state's attorney--
who had sort of been implicated
in the Laquan McDonald coverup.
So this is something that's
happening in different places.
Krasner, I would say, is
the most remarkable example.
And he's now got a general
election ahead of him,
a thing I didn't
say this morning.
And he's now got a general
election ahead of him.
And that's gonna be a
really fascinating fight.
And what's going to be even more
interesting is if he wins, OK.
What does the rubber
hitting the road look like?
Talking about all
this is one thing.
But the reason that there's a
lot of hope around prosecutors
is because a lot of empirical
work that's been done
shows that prosecutors more
than any other single actors
in the system were the ones
driving mass incarceration.
It wasn't mandatory minimums.
It wasn't statutes being passed.
It was prosecutors
using their discretion
to charge five crimes
for a max of 20
rather than one crime
for a max of five.
And when they charged five
crimes with a max of 20,
and they plea down
to 15 or 12, you've
got someone who's doing
a 12-year bid as opposed
to a one-year bid.
That's the latitude
that prosecutors have,
and the latitude they have
in a system in which, again--
you've got to remind
yourself this all the time,
particularly if you're not
someone who's spending a lot
of time in the criminal
justice system--
the criminal justice system is
a factory for producing pleas.
Your input are arrests,
and the outputs are pleas.
There are no trials in America.
It's a rounding error, trials.
All the pop culture
representations
of American criminal justice
are the rounding error.
What it is is it's Lucy
with the chocolates.
That's a night in court
in any major municipality.
And so because it's a machine
that produces pleas out
of the input of arrests,
these two main fulcrums
are what you're
pleaing to, which
is the knob that the
prosecutors can turn,
and how many arrests
you're getting,
which is the knob
the police can turn.
So those are two of the
regulators on that system.
And those are two places--
what are police
arresting folks for,
and what are prosecutors
charging and accepting pleas?
TORRENCE BOONE: And those
prosecutors, though,
are connected to the
political machine.
CHRIS HAYES: I mean,
Europe thinks it's nuts
that we elect prosecutors.
Right?
I mean, it's literally
in the Bible, right?
The scene where Jesus is killed
is essentially the punishment
being put up to the crowd.
Pontius Plate's like,
what should I do?
We want Barabbas, right?
Now The crowd, literally,
it's like the iconic example
of the crowd gone
wild, is in the context
of a crowd selecting a
punishment for Jesus Christ.
But that's basically
what DA elections are.
We put people
politically in charge
of making these decisions
that in other systems
are insulated from
democratic input
and are appointed
like a judiciary
and probably produce far
less punitive outcomes
for that reason.
TORRENCE BOONE: We'll
take another question,
but I do want to come
back to what can we do?
What advice would you give
us individually and as
an organization in
terms of addressing
some of these issues?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I feel like the
Democrats have not
been particularly good
at making racial justice
or criminal justice
reform a national issue.
I feel like it came up at the
end of Barack Obama's time,
and then it was like
there's other issues.
This goes back down.
And then even pre-Barack Obama.
But what is the
argument for really
making this stuff a national
issue for Democrats,
when it feels like everything
else is on fire right now?
CHRIS HAYES: Yeah.
I think it's hard to
get the oxygen for it
as a national issue for
Democrats right now, frankly.
There are these stories
that I tell myself on my way
into work everyday,
like we're gonna
get this in the goddamn
show if it kills me.
And, like, nine times
out of 10, we don't.
And then I go
home, and I'm like,
I failed again to get
this thing in the show.
And the other day,
I went in with--
Sessions just issued
this sentencing memo.
Are you guys familiar with this?
Right.
We got it in the show.
And I was like--
but that's a testament
to how hard it is
to sort of treat these issues.
My answer to that are twofold.
One, the Democratic Party's
been incredibly complicit
in the buildup of
the carceral state.
And James Forman's book
is great about this.
Washington DC, African
American Democratic leaders
were part of building this up.
The upside is that
most of this stuff
is being driven
at a local level.
In a tangible sense,
better funding
for public defenders and better
prosecutors being elected
in major cities
around America would
have a more tangible
effect, most likely,
in some ways than who
the attorney general is.
Attorney general has a
huge amount of power.
It matters a tremendous amount
that it's Jeff Sessions.
That's not good for
reform of the system.
But if Democrats focus and
focus in those environments--
the Krasner case
is so fascinating
because that's a primary.
So focusing in the
context of places
like Cy Vance in
Manhattan, Brooklyn DA,
focusing on those
offices, there's
a lot to be done at that level.
TORRENCE BOONE: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Something I wonder--
what you think
of the prospects of
trying to involve people
around prosecution
or law enforcement,
getting them more onboard
with criminal justice reform?
And I think about this even
when I'm recounting, like,
a local assembly
person who's very
friendly with local
police, which is great.
But it's easy to
get very pessimistic
if I'm reading, say, personal
accounts or people in my friend
circles who work
in law enforcement.
And their perspective
is so far from where
I can get to in terms of where
they think the problem is.
CHRIS HAYES: That's
a great question.
So I think there's been
some real progress on this.
And I think that you've seen a
lot of police representatives
come around on things like
decriminalization of marijuana,
stuff like that, that
they used to oppose.
If I'm not mistaken, I think
the professional organization
of the American
Society of Prosecutors
put out a critical statement
about the Sessions charging
memo, which also was
amazing to me, which
reflects this idea
that we don't actually
think this is the way to go.
So there's some light
and some space there.
The other side of it is that--
and again, to sort
of put yourself
in the shoes of the people
that are manning the system--
police particularly- and
this is true of prosecutors,
particularly true of police--
they're spending
all day every day
interacting with people
that are in distress
and are in their
worst situation.
No one calls the cops
to bake them cookies.
You call the cops when there's
distress and there's disorder
and there's trauma.
And there's a real taxing
effect psychologically
on being introduced
to that all the time.
Now, people will note,
rightly, that they're not
the only people
that are introduced
to that kind of thing.
There are social
workers and child
protective services workers
and emergency room doctors
and all kinds of
people that are going
through jobs in which they're
exposed to this all the time.
But there's a psychological
toll, I think,
it takes on everyone
involved in the system that
is part of kind of
reproducing that punitiveness.
And I don't know the
solution for that.
But I think it is important
to have empathy for that
as a psychological toll.
There's a lot of sort of
trauma through osmosis
that's happening.
And cops are lied to all
the time, constantly.
And it's easy to think
everyone's a liar.
All of that--
I don't know the solution
and whether that's a training
solution, whether
that's the sort of way
that we think about the
profession of policing.
But it's a real
thing what you're
saying, when you talk
about that perspective.
There's a real thing
about police culture
that is really deeply
viscerally opposed to reform.
And that's something that
has to be dealt with.
TORRENCE BOONE: So
we're incredibly
action-oriented and passionate
about making a difference.
That's what characterizes
the culture of our company.
What else can we do,
other than engagement
in the political process,
which you've covered?
CHRIS HAYES: I mean,
I think, actually,
that's the most important thing.
I mean, the point
of this book is
there are political
situations in America
that were essentially the
product of special interests.
Like the bankruptcy bill
was not some big democratic
mobilization to make
bankruptcy harder for debtors.
That was basically written in
a backroom by bank lobbyists.
That's not true of the
criminal justice system.
That was democratically
brought about in election
after election for assembly,
counsel, state senate, city
council, governor, district
attorney, attorney general,
senator, Congress,
election after election,
banging that drum of fear.
And it only is
going to be unmade
through democratic means.
It's not going to be unmade
through policy conferences
and think tanks.
The policy solutions are there.
What has to change
fundamentally are the politics.
And people have to
invest themselves
in changing the politics
of that and decide
this is an issue that
they're going to care about
and prioritize and get
invested in, again,
at very local levels.
There are a million fights
about criminal justice happening
in New York City, like cash
bail, the fate of Rikers.
This is stuff right here,
right now that you can actually
have a really, really powerful
voice in because there's
a low quotient of
citizens who are
raising their voices about it.
And that's a real opportunity.
TORRENCE BOONE: Terrific.
Chris is going to
be signing books.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
CHRIS HAYES: Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, that was awesome.
TORRENCE BOONE: All right, man.
CHRIS HAYES: Thanks.